what are you trying to achieve
and you'll be wanting good goals opening
okay so the first thing that you should
be thinking about is your fair share of
the center you want to control your your
opponent's got his ideas you got your
ideas but you want your fair share of
the center that's point number one point
number two in the words of the Brits you
want to get the bits out you want
development you want good squares for
your pieces you want to have harmonious
development that number three is you
really want a safe chain all other
things being able command if your king
is safe you're coming out of the opening
you should feel pretty good about what's
happened so far
number four you don't want massive pawn
weaknesses if there's been trades equal
trades that's fine but you don't want to
have a situation where your structure is
decimated and the next thing you know
the whole game all you're doing is
defending weak squares weak pawns and
there's no counter play nothing to do
but seize the defensive as we say so
once again four things your fair share
of the Senate harmonious development
safe King sound pawn structure that's
all you really want after that you just
play chess you just play chess so in
this game we have the last round and
Sarah sharing Sarah Shang she I Ben
could probably correct me she's one of
the very very few women females that
I've ever played in the US Junior
Championship by you by far it wasn't
even when I was I played in a number of
US Junior Championships from 1976 to
1979 and it wasn't even close there
wasn't a female in within striking
distance there was just nobody who would
even you
consider putting in against these
juniors so Sarah's participation was
really extraordinarily unique to begin
with and she was the lowest rated player
in the field by far that didn't mean
that her games weren't competitive some
were not all of them she lost some quite
badly
one she absolutely should have won I
mean she deserved a victory in one of
her games and I think she's lost 8
Andrew won so she went through the
tournament a half a point in the last
round she has white so she has a bad
tournament and she's anxious to you know
salvage some pride or what-have-you and
she's playing against Sam savvy on the
youngest player in the tournament and
the kid is just plain tremendously and
he's got aspirations of winning the
tournament if he could win and certain
results on the top boards go well he
could be the US junior champion so black
has everything to play for
white you know wants to salvage her
tournament so she opens d4 I happen to
be a queen pong player by the way d4
Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 so the first
things that we can say about these three
opening moves from white is look good
look good you know you're you're playing
in the center you're trying to control
the center and we can say in particular
the depands on d4 and c4 White's
occupying the center okay black from his
part has played restrained Knight f6
East 6th these are the most popular
moves and now with this move Bishop b4
instead of instead of let's say playing
four and occupying the center with d5
black instead goes for the pin oops
I did something wrong yeah okay like I
said just because the technology is
advanced doesn't mean that I have
assured before okay so we have the
nimzowitsch defense bishop before
pinning the knight to the king I mean
why would prior to this move White's
intention was to try to occupy the
center with efore so the move Bishop
before is aimed to prevent white from
doing that hey Sam yeah it's your game
you see you inspire me ah he sensed I
remember as a kid looking at this
position and I was saying to myself the
knight on f6 the bishop on b4 is aimed
at preventing efore is that correct the
knight on f6 and the bishop on before
that I was very contrarian or maybe even
stubborn when I was a kid
and I was thinking to myself why can't I
play
efore like isn't that a kind of a cool
move so my analysis I remember thinking
about this Knight takes e4 Queen g4 so I
was thinking gosh with my threats to
capture this pawn on g7 oops excuse me
to capture this knight on e4 who's there
go stop that I thought the only move was
Knight take c3 so I was very happy
new variation yeah go okay so far so
good
I've lost upon and frankly I've lost
tonight a bit in my mind's eye I was
thinking that this thread on Queen takes
g7 was extremely powerful so again you
know I was just a kid my analysis I
played a3 so what I was counting on is
that I want to take blacks Bishop if it
was my turn I would take blacks Bishop
but if you notice the knight is then
trapped so not only would I win the
piece I had sacrificed back I would
I've sacrificed a piece and upon so in
my mind's eye I'm thinking that if if
it's my turn I get to take the bishop
and then in the resulting position the
Knights trapped I get to take it so I
would win two pieces so again you know I
kind of like a kid I'm thinking like
what can black do I was thinking that
black could well first of all that's a
good question what do you what's what's
blacks best move now
any suggestions are more than welcome
what's blacks best move
Bishop back to FA precisely Bishop back
to f8 precisely that was the move I
missed seriously I must have spent I
don't want to say days that's ridiculous
that's being over and I'm saying it's
been you know good Bishop e7 is a good
move also but simply Bishop retreats
that hadn't occurred to me I was
thinking that black should play Knight a
to check which is a sit ridiculous move
I would take he would take I would take
and I'd be better because as soon as the
rook moved to f8 then I would recapture
and I was WOW White has everything and
black has absolutely nothing so it never
really occurred to me that after a three
the only other retreat that was going
through my mind was this one Bishop b4
okay so I have figured okay if I take
the knight he would take recapture and
then I was thinking well gee after b4
bishop goes back I can always trap his
Bishop with this move but in the
meantime I can take rook f8 Bishop h6
Queen e7c five so this was going to be
my secret weapon is gonna be players who
played the nihms Oh again Smee I was
gonna sacrifice the pawn and then some
very dear friend of mine pointed out
that well gee yes you know I hate to
burst your bubble but after Bishop f8 no
I didn't do that right after Bishop f8
all you can do is win back the the
knight and then you're a pawn down there
just a second so after Bishop f8 I'm a
pawn down and black and play I don't
care d6
night-night and he's fine and then Sam's
move would be even a better choice than
that which is this so remain mine so the
idea here is that was drew boy hey stop
that
so if I take upon new variation he would
go Bishop f6 I come back I'm trying to
trap this knight Knight a 4 so that
didn't work so in this position sorry
sorry sorry sorry
takes your main mine castles Bishop h6
doesn't win an exchange because of
Bishop f6 up on down but this is the way
I was taught literally to analyze
openings is to just question everything
if from the basic position of the
nimzo-indian if from the basic position
of the nimzo-indian black is trying to
prevent white from playing efore well
what would happen if I play d4 why
doesn't eat or work by answering these
questions before I got into tournament
play I didn't think about them at the
board right they had have been answered
but you know you can imagine yourself
sitting there at a tournament game and
suddenly Kate get a creative inspiration
hey why don't they play e4 in this
position well now I know okay so what
Sarah did instead was played Queen c2 oh
pardon me she played III yes okay the
main move Sam b6 so this is all common
known as the Rubinstein variation of the
nihms oh gee - now Sarah made a very
strange decision logically what white
has done is brought the knight on Ji Won
to protect the knight on c3 so that if
the bishop captured
knight on c3 white would recapture with
the night and not have to suffer tavella
a damaged pawn structure which is how I
started the lecture what are the four
things that you want from the opening
okay so everybody I think the main line
would be a three and black has a
critical choice does he want to give up
the two bishops Yes No maybe or does he
want to retreat his bishop to say II
seven
yes no maybe but in any case I do think
that the move a to a3 is critical and
earlier in the tournament as Sarah had
played the move Knight g3 was this error
in her game with Daniel or Jeffery and
got a bad position and lost and then and
I after the game had explained to her
our perspectives that maybe white should
play play a three and Lori a three just
different movies we just put the
question to the bishop and so when she
went into a deep thought Ben and I were
jokingly saying to each other did she
forget you know like our recommendation
of a three okay so now comes c5 d5 takes
takes takes takes so we'll start again
here so again when I started the lecture
we talked about what you want to achieve
from any opening whether you're a
beginner Grandmaster you're for sure the
center harmonious development for your
pieces safe King and not a hopeless or
terrible compromise pawn structure so in
a sense if we take a look at White's
position there's some violations of
okay I don't think that the knight on c3
the night on g3 are so harmonious that's
somehow a little bit of a violation the
king
definitely a violation were not Castle
we we do white should be very very proud
of her occupation of the center and her
share of the center and so far her
structure isn't compromised which is
okay so some gives and some takes
takeaways all right so we continue black
for her his part he's happy not not a
problem
castles safe King he for rook e8 and now
comes the crucial well a very critical
moment in the game Ben and I expected f3
okay so we were thinking that maybe
Sarah had you know very cleverly
prepared disposition that although she's
compromised her King's position look at
what she has in return she has his
beautiful I called us the corral right
so you think of a fence that is
corralling the pony the pony I'm on f6
the pawns on e4 d5 f 3 all stop that
knight on f6 removing so white has
occupied the center big time safe center
maybe maybe in the future this night on
g3 has a possibility to advance to f5
and in the meantime King comes rook
slides over we could Castle by hand so
here we had actually been and I guess
yes double
a seven this guy is right so yeah so the
King right so here again
Ben and I were having this discussion as
to maybe you know Sarah really had
prepared this really well and and you
know got something Sam by just by
complete coincidence the player of the
black site Sam savvy on the silver
medalist in the u.s. Jam Junior
Championship is here no doubts you
expected f3 and your intention I suppose
was to play d6 and so so your intention
in the game was after d6 Bishop f4
Knight f6 to d7 to set to sacrifice the
pawn on d6 yeah I can imagine
one of the things that you know start to
do right exactly I was about to say just
be a little careful that this Bishop
over here doesn't hang it isn't left out
to dry because of 97 so we'll go back
for a moment so we're going to imagine
f3 we're gonna imagine take okay whether
it will transpose in a moment d6
okay so Bishop but essentially this was
the intention of black was to sacrifice
this pawn on d6 so we'll just continue
the line takes Queen I suppose tags
I suppose tanks and since you're
attacking this pawn I'm whoops I wasn't
the move I wanted I was going to defend
it with something
O'Casey 495 so it's a pawn sacrifice for
quick development and maybe black can
look at this white King and say you're
compromised
so I cancel they don't want to play that
so that was let's say the expected
variation for yourself and probably the
expected variation for Ben and I we
thought that after f3 white might be on
to something
and black might be under pressure thanks
to White's occupation of the center
instead Sarah went for the gold and when
she first played this move let's be fair
to her we were really impressed with a
holy cow Queen f3 my goodness that's a
very strong move white develops his
queen her queen and if it's her turn
like a move like Bishop g5 would simply
be devastating because blacks pawns are
going to be doubled on f6 so our first
impression of Queen f3 was like oh my
gosh
Sam's in deep trouble what on earth
could he possibly do to save his bacon
any ideas for black how come black deal
with what he's facing it's clear that
white just wants to play Bishop g5 and
you know jump with her Knight maybe the
FI bring her up to e1 and white will
have a domination of the center so any
any ideas what black might do pardon me
please
h6 okay this is a kind of this move no
well no not at all the move h6 is
designed to stop the bishop on g5 and
under normal circumstances the move h6
would be fine but from White's point of
view that would be great because that
would be a tempo and that would mean
that
maybe why could develop her Bishop to f4
and if black were to play move like d6
maybe bring and we can see that White's
developed developing her pieces and even
though her King is not the greatest then
maybe maybe white was intention is to
solve it with h3 King g1 and King h2 and
in the meantime what is left is that
white has a great occupation in the
center so we were thinking holy cow this
is sure looks strong for Saira and Sam
came up with a very clever refutation he
actually took the night Bishop takes c3
B takes c3 and after the Queen c7 it was
sort of like Eureka Oh obvious obvious
she's white loses her efore pawn and
because of a trick of Knight d2 now the
problem from White's point of view is if
she simply allows the move Knight takes
e4 not only is she losing a pond she's
losing any chances for the of any
advantage she would just lose a pond and
lose the game so we saw that after
Bishop g5 Knight takes e4 this pin is an
illusion and after Bishop takes oops see
there's a reason and there's a reason
there's a reason why you'd like to be
castled and you'd like to have a safe
King in the opening because you get fort
when you don't you get forked and this
is what what we thought and we more or
less kind of decided in our minds that
at this point
Sam had refuted Sarah's play but then
you know like we got sucked into this
game this game was like started getting
more and more interesting as we started
questioning her what's going on so we
saw Knight takes e4 Bishop takes a seven
here
here here all very forcing play here
white is a pawn down if you put upon on
b2 white is very very happy he would no
longer be a pawn down in fact she'd
being an ending where she'd stand
considerably better we started thinking
wait a minute
black has issues first of all this
knight on b8 can't come to c6 obviously
if black has to play d6 and Knight d7
well that's going to cost him a temple
or to notice that blacks King is on the
back rank and in a back rank mating
situation and we started thinking to
ourselves well my goodness what if Sarah
played Knight a5 black could you know
hey black has to move his rook rook e5
is the only move and then we started
thinking well the rooks attacks the
knight on e5 f5 so the King returned the
attack returns the favor king of for
attacking the rook defending the knight
f7 f6 so again it was like one of those
games that Ben and I couldn't turn away
from because it just kept sucking as in
and grabbing our attention and we
started thinking well does Sarah have
enough compensation for upon clearly she
has the better development and now the
whole game hinges on whether or not she
can play rook h1 to e1 okay so if white
plays this move what on earth could
black do essentially if you don't if you
don't take that if you try to take if
you don't take this pawn pardon me this
Knight on
be eight is it a little stuck even when
it goes to a six notice that it's a
little stuck and that you know it could
go to c7 but cancel and there's ideas of
d6
to stop the Knights further development
so we thought rook H e1 holy cow black
would play d6 Knight takes d6 night here
white has regained her pawn and we'd
like White's position that is to say
this pawn on d5 is the most important
pawn on the board and we thought that it
would be black who has to equalize maybe
that's true maybe it's not been said
we'll wait a minute how about winning a
piece how about the move ah sorry Sam is
going to correct me and say say again
please say g6 is a new variation we did
not look at the move g6 you did so how
would the very oh I'm sorry that would
that my pen my stylus just getting used
to it 96 rook takes d5 check okay
Wow night b5 a six-night c7 check and
your you got it and so the background
pin is broken so let's go back for a
second
wow that is a tricky trap Iver iation so
g6 which I I were at during the game
our main variation that Ben and I had
been looking at was g5 and we were just
having a lot of fun I'm telling you
folks this was a very enjoyable game to
comment upon but again let's start with
g6 96 yes rook takes d5 rook e8 King g7
Wow okay so rookie 7 is your perpetual
check yes
sorry you're getting maded so you're
saying that instead of getting mated you
would have to go back and then just
simply exactly so you're simply saying
that but that white has a perpetual
check in the position but you suggested
another alternative for white all right
use yes new mainline not taking the
night rookie seven King age six rook h8
and yes yes oh yes I remember this now
for those of you who thought the the
checkmate was gonna come in the corner I
got a surprise remember when this line
the plate White's King started on f3 so
we had quite a dance to get to this
position that's very nice
rookie Juan GFI oops not takes but g5
check new main light so White's King
presumably yes pause pause pause King h5
f5 correct
okay so sorry how does it go check yes
yes so we're threatening made into f5
check
and then rook d5 check oh it's it
transposes okay so how do you avoid the
transposition are you playing here this
is the other perpetual line yeah okay
yeah black stacks is a little harder now
lets us go back here for a moment
because this is all did there was
something about this game that had a
very natural flow like everything that
black did seemed real good like he's won
upon and you know if he's just got the
right Tempe to consolidate which
actually happened in the game black wins
easily the problem is is that what if
white plays ultra aggressive in the game
sarah has played h4 and that was
absolutely the vital tempo that black
needed to gain an advantage and had she
played rook he1 yes very good again we
were looking so our main line and we'll
come back to this g6 move in just a
moment our main mine had been g5 check
which looks the most attractive so white
has no choice but has to move her king
to g4 and no it's blacks turn like it
black tries to bail out and play plays a
weak move like Knight a6 well then after
rook takes g5 pawn takes King takes
White's not only won her pawn back but
if you notice this knight on f5 is in a
dominating position and this knight on a
six part of me has been corralled for
one of a better expression Corral so we
like White's position very much so black
really doesn't have any choice other
than in this position to play a
five check okay
so cool H five check so whites losing
their piece by force but King takes H
five rook takes effort here we pause
here we pause because if we're white in
this position and then is a very
important thing is we need to learn to
use our ability to calculate okay so so
instantly your first absolute instinct
right out of the box in this position
ought to be to play king g6 like that's
like that should be the overriding
instinct that you have when you play the
move King g6 you put the Kings in our
position so that any back ragging check
is checkmate
so King g6 not only that not only do you
put the Kings in opposition to one
another but how sweet it is you get the
benefit of tacking the rook she had seen
the move king g6
as basically her best and only option
and then after rook e5 she had dismissed
the line which was very very very
unfortunate because King g6 the first
move that should be that should be your
first move your instincts here tell you
king g6 is the best move rookie five is
the showstopper very unfortunately she
didn't consider the line rook e8 so once
again we're gonna look at rook e8 king
f7 rook e1 and sorry Sam what what
variation did you you wanted to play
rook e5 yes you didn't want to play g4
check right right okay so we were
looking just a second let's just let's
just show you one of the variations we
were looking at - and if I recall your
original intention was to play g4 check
right it would the benefit of hindsight
do you think that
check was your best or would you have
played is it wonderful please tell us
why or plays tell me okay so we did
yes okay yes correct new main new
variation yes King yes in 95 but before
before yes yes yes yes here you want to
play King that's what I'm trying yeah
b3 correct correct
we take upon I suppose yes those pawns
are tough Wow take a to g6 check I'm
sorry Sam do you say you have some okay
in in this position it's white - it's
black to move right okay
how about one one more time okay now in
threatening maiden wand so even with the
benefit of Sam having hindsight and
working with chess engines and so again
you just saw how we got drawn deeper
this was the last round with the US
Junior Championship at stake and we're
ending up you know infatuated with this
game Arnie yes Sam ended up winning the
game but Daniel when he needed help from
Robert Perez to save to to make his him
the US junior champion so we're gonna go
back back back to this position and your
original intention was g4 check yes
oops not there but there okay
and now yes so
ah right I remember so here there's a
wonderful trick by black so blacks
wonderful trick was that this move was
kind of outside of his consciousness and
he was more focused upon the normal keep
the centralization but now rookie five
is or it's a horse of a different
feather because white wants to keep this
pin but unfortunately his king is in
check so he ends up having me to take
this pawn that now there's an there's
another strange variation which Sam just
mentioned which went takes takes takes
with the idea that when the night goes
to a six well suddenly the night is
corralled in another way and by the way
in this case there's three connected
pass pawns and they sure look good right
okay so we're gonna go back back back
so King e7 knew me still very so that's
right king of right once again we have
some variation that may look a little
bit like this but h4 and it looks to me
like White's just simply too fast
what
so but maybe in this position so you're
saying that even after your your trappy
you really and and what was the look
that the line after King H for Sam rook
takes d5 and can't white we've a mating
net of some sorts check okay oh do we
start with G for Rupp g8 check first is
the best
oh my now we we also have ideas evil
ideas like g5 - what's your view that
should this be very good for white then
Sam sorry
so Rupp GA check King here and what
should I do Ben
it's a very strong Jeep on
bid okay just come back come back to
this position for a moment because is
that is that kind of your feeling that
this rook and Knight is just so terrible
no yes so again one of so this is a
strange kind of tail that right right so
we going back to this position and who
would have thunk it that when our
initial reaction once again when we saw
the move Queen f3 was bordering on
euphoric we kind of thought wow you know
Sarah she's ignored our advice to play a
three she's played her Mo's relatively
up fast okay she's prepared this
position and we can see that with the
move Bishop g5 she is going to be
dominant then you know because we didn't
see Sam's refutation it was sort of like
Odin ah that's a wide a clever move new
variation so maybe your queen e7 was the
inaccurate move black can always draw
really okay so the point was was that
when we saw Queen e7 again for the first
time vennen eyes reaction was oh dear
that refutes Aris setup because of this
Knight d2 fork and then we saw this
whole piece hacker it's
more enthusiastic but you're saying that
maybe your Queenie 7 was wrong and that
maybe 94 was more oh you're saying that
in this position your move Queenie 7
according the computer that this ends in
zero zeros or draw but your computer is
suggesting to you that had you wanted
was Knight takes e4 so if you could call
recall for as what this is black White's
best move it Snyder okay okay first
impression is this net whoops sorry was
the knight it stood badly night
the g3 rookie 4 and if I play f3 new
variation the idea you can play d7 d6
Wow Wow
okay because you're upon up
fantastically intriguing variations one
of the first things I you know again
like that experience of of you know just
do the rook and Knight being pinned on
the back row
yeah the rook and Knight being pinned on
the back row man my when that happened
to me I felt so physically helpless man
I was like pinned on the back row when I
see such structure Sam the first thing I
look at is blacks King and I understand
this move Bishop f4 very very much
because basically your idea is you want
to dominate this night so that after it
comes to a 6 its Corral and that might
be my word of the evening but when I
look at blacks King my first instinct is
Bishop h6 because I think in my mind's
eye all I got to do - checkmate blacks
King is to play h4 and rook h3 how do
you how would you defend the white idea
d7 d6h 497 rook h3 King h8 so I go rook
g3 and you're in time to stop Bishop g7
and check
me I should play rook takes g8 yes
that's the best okay as you like okay so
I've got I've got evil intentions yeah
okay
now yeah this knight on e5 tips sorry
this night on ePHI became boss so
unfortunately the desirable Bishop h6
it's not that easy okay so we go back to
this position for a second I'm wondering
about the combination of the two ideas
so imagine I were to begin with h4 first
you would probably play d6 pardon sorry
correct d6
yes okay so now I am trying to combine
the two ideas so I play route I did okay
this was just a this was just a an
aberration I mean I didn't like the King
on whoops I didn't like the King on
earth huh
right right well also you were in an
awkward situation because essentially
the tournament standings were such that
you need to win with black so you have
to take risks of some sort and to get
her out of her comfort zone so I
understand and it just turned out that
this game was one of the really
interesting and complex games where it's
rather rare that just right out of the
opening everything seemed to be turned
into a combination and the entire
variation hinged on one tempo yes yes
yes of the game unfortunately the finish
was a true true anticlimax so instead of
capturing this pond which was super
desirous Sam played rook c5 king d5 king
takes rook your check yeah here and
Sarah could actually resign at this
point I'll just say that she played on a
little bit too long because again her
book she's playing essentially the game
a rook behind at this point she can do
nothing and this is where she stopped so
with this victory seemed to clear silver
second place in the tournament by the
way let us applaud you saying wherever
he was the adi god he went
you